turning to consumer news general motors  will soon begin production on an  all-electric chevrolet  silverado pickup the truck will be  manufactured at a new assembly plant for  electric vehicles which is currently  under construction in detroit  this is part of the company's 2.2  billion dollar investment  in electric vehicles all right first it  was toilet paper  now there's a ketchup shortage with so  many to-go orders the world's largest  maker of ketchup says it's running out  of all those tiny packets  uh-huh at the same time packet prices  are going up as well  heinz plans to increase production by  about 25 percent  to meet that demand